deutschland atmet auf denn die
mutmaßlichen polizisten killer sind
festgenommen in der kleinstadt kusel in
der nähe von kaiserslautern wurden
gestern eine 24-jährige
polizeianwärterin und ein 29 jähriger
polizist mit gezielten kopfschüssen
getötet und bild hat jetzt exklusive
bilder zu den festnahmen der beiden
dringend tatverdächtigen um 17 30 schlug
ein spezialeinsatzkommando zu zwei
wohnobjekte und ein fahrzeug wurden von
den schwer bewaffneten beamten
durchsucht dabei konnten die beiden
männer widerstandslos festgenommen
werden den ganzen tag hatte die polizei
nach den mutmaßlichen tätern gefahndet
wer ist andreas johannes es einer der
beiden mutmaßlichen täter und er ist
familienvater im vergangenen jahr mit
einer bäckerei pleite gegangen da auch
jäger und wild händler soll er gewesen
sein seine jagd lizenz die soll er
allerdings verloren haben und bei der
bäckerei steht jetzt unser reporter
steffen meier guten tag stefan was
kannst du uns zu dem mutmaßlichen täter
johannes es sagen ja guten morgen nach
berlin wir sind hier in sulzbach vor
einer der bäcker filialen die einst von
andreas johannes betrieben wurde wie ihr
schon gesagt hat er ist im vergangenen
jahr pleite gegangen im august hat ein
neuer pächter die filialen übernommen er
hat die die bäckerei die in der fünften
generation
geleitet hat hatte weitergefahren das
geht aus unseren unterlagen hervor und
es gab auch
2009/10 schon ärger um sein sein stil
wie er die bäckerei geführt hat er so
löhne über monate nicht bezahlt haben
soll auch sehr schroff mit seinen
mitarbeitern umgegangen seien das hat
man gehört und das gerät es auch von
geldproblemen soll immer mal wieder geld
aus der kasse auf verschwunden sein also
es gibt bei ihm geschäftlich alles
andere als optimal
steffen du konntest du ja mit einem
nachbarn reden der die gestrige
festnahme live miterlebt hat aber nur
ganz kurz reinhören
um 17 uhr 15 war ich auch unten hoch und
dann habe ich nur reifen quietschen
gehört und aus dem auto sind raus
gesprungen dann bin ich hoch auf die
straße bin dahin gegangen und da habe
ich halt gesehen wie sie das haus
umstellt haben und dann ging es schlag
auf schlag das sind die polizisten die
autos hier angefangen gekommen in
paketweise
und haben das haus umstellten irgendwann
kam halt eine person ans fenster wie
haben sie das gesehen haben gesagt er
soll die hände hoch nehmen soll am
fenster stehen bleiben und dann hat es
ein paar mal krummel das sind die mit
mehreren leuten abends haushalt im
ganzen sek kommando
und ja dann ein paar minuten später
haben sie den rausgebracht hat er noch
in der weiße schürze an gehabt einen
weißen kittel so ein schlachter kittel
mit blut dran er war gefesselt und dann
haben sie ihn ins auto gelegten
weggefallen also daher was können sie
über den nachbarn sagen hat man da schon
mal was gehört waren der polizeieinsätze
schon mal in der vergangenheit gut wir
haben hier schon stören in den letzten
jahren immer wieder weil da an der ecke
einsätze von der polizei mitbekommen wo
wildfang hat angeblich oder wo er mit
der pistole über über die straße
gelaufen ist besoffen war man einsetzt
dann kann ich mich noch erinnern
und da waren immer wieder einsetzen mit
der polizei wo die aber auch die
polizisten sind nie alleine dahin also
das wissen wir sind immer fünf sechs
autos dann direkt gekommen auch
saarbrücken das daran kann ich mich
immer erinnern also alleine ist da auch
nie eine reihenweise den immer nie
einschätzen konnten gerade mit alkohol
mit allem müssen die nie wieder drauf
ist steffen wie gehen die menschen in
sulzbach und der umgebung mit dieser
schrecklichen tat um ja also ist es
nicht nur sulzbach muss man sagen es ist
das gesamte saarland denn es hat ja
eigentlich in die katastrophe die
tragödie hat in kusel in rheinland-pfalz
direkt an der grenze zum saarland hat
begonnen und es hat sich
herauskristallisiert am ende war nur
saarländer beteiligt die beiden otra die
polizistin und der polizist kam aus dem
saarland aus dem nordsaarland bzw
aus dem osten land und auch die beiden
täter die mutmaßlichen mörder stammen
hier aus dem saarland wurden beide im
sulzbach festgenommen und es ist so am
anfang war es sehr verwirrend das warten
nach die sich die suche nach der
stecknadel im heuhaufen es gab mehrere
orte die die polizei gestern abgefahren
hat wo sek einsätze waren
und ja man hat man ist immer von zwei
tätern ausgegangen und man hatte aber
nur die spur zu andreas johannes
es da er seinen ausweis da am tatort
verloren hatte beziehungsweise dort
befunden wurde und man hat sich also
dann auch sulzbach konzentriert weil das
auch so sein sein sein zentraler ort war
er hat vier kinder
und ja er hat aber auch wohnadressen in
hamburg gehabt und in spiesen-elversberg
also es war ein bisschen diffus wo er
sich auch auffällt das war sehr schwer
die leute zu finden stellte jetzt haben
viel über andreas johannes es besprochen
was ist denn über den zweiten
mutmaßlichen täter bekannt der zweite
mutmaßliche täter ist noch die große
unbekannte
der nachbar das ist die person über die
der nachbar eben gerade gesprochen hat
der mann
wegen dem die ganzen polizeieinsätze
stattgefunden haben ja über ihn wird
sagt dass er sehr aggressiv aufgetreten
ist dass er observiert war und ja auch
in der nachbarschaft viel unfrieden
verbreitet hat die leute haben sich wohl
von ihm fern gehalten hatten auch
teilweise angst vor ihm es ist von
alkoholproblemen die die rede also das
ja das beschäftigt die leute und im
saarland ist es so die die trauer ist
riesig groß ist es teilweise halbmast
die fahnen sind auf halbmast
gesetzt und auch der der
ministerpräsident tobias hans hat schon
an tweet abgesetzt ein trauerlied also
es ist nicht nur sulzbachs betroffen ist
und dann das gesamte saarland
und die leute fragen sich auch was
wirklich dahinter steckt also sie sagen
wegen wilderei zwei menschen umzubringen
das ist so eine wahnsinnstat na also
gestern abend als wir dort vor ort waren
die leute haben immer wieder den kopf
geschüttet und haben gesagt was für ein
irrsinn was für ein irrsinn staat bald
die beiden polizisten umzubringen
und sie fragen sich auch ist da mehr
dahinter als nur diese diese wilderei
geschichte
steffen meyer dankeschön für diese ganze
aktuellen informationen
und im studio begrüßen wir jetzt den
chef der deutschen polizeigewerkschaft
rainer wendt guten tag herr weltökonom
montag wie sind streifenpolizisten
ausgerüstet wie muss man sich das
vorstellen
wir sind sehr gut ausgerüstet zumindest
sehr viel besser als noch in meiner
aktiven polizisten zeit dass die
dienstherren
auch in rheinland pfalz beispielsweise
das innenministerium hat sehr viel für
die schutzausstattung der einsatzkräfte
getan sind gut bewaffnet sie haben
tragen schutzwesten sie haben sie führen
mit schutzhelmen besondere ballistische
schutzhelme die bei besonders
lebensbedrohliche lage ein zur anwendung
kommen das heißt die andere die
ausrüstung hat sich massiv verbessert in
den letzten jahren man muss sagen dass
wir auch leider erforderlich nun haben
die beiden polizisten jetzt bei ihrem
einsatz diesen hätten zum beispiel nicht
getragen man geht ja auch erst mal bei
so einem streifen einsatz nicht davon
aus dass der bewaffnete täter drin
sitzen wie bereitet man sich generell
auf solche einsätze vor womit muss man
rechnen der polizist gefahren gemerkt
und das wissen die einsatzkräfte auch
trotzdem sind wir eine bürger polizei
das heißt wir gehen nicht hoch gerüstet
mit helm und maschinenpistole auf
bürgerinnen und bürger zu gleichzeitig
weiß man natürlich dass eine solche
situation
morgens in der dunkelheit eine
verkehrskontrolle immer auch eine
gefährliche situation ist deshalb gibt
es ein sicherungsposten bei zwei
einsatzbeamten das gebiet die tragen
schutzwesten sie wissen das ist eine
gefährliche situation weil sie
unkalkulierbar ist wird man schlicht
nicht weißt wer sitzt in diesem fahrzeug
drin und diese abwägung einerseits
zwischen bürgernähe auf der einen seite
und ein die sicherung auf der anderen
seite muss immer wieder neu getroffen
werden was wir nicht wollen sind die
amerikanische verhältnisse wo die
menschen sobald sie bei der
verkehrskontrolle angetroffen werden
sofort aktiv mit der schusswaffe
vorgehalten werden und angeschrieben
werden teilweise das ist nicht das was
wir uns vorstellen aber es wird ein
gewisses gefahren und wie gehen
teilweise die sehr jungen kollegen
intern mit dieser tragödie um weil sie
können sich vorstellen dass nicht nur
bei den jungen kolleginnen und kollegen
sondern wir insgesamt die emotionale
beteiligung in der polizei sehr hoch ist
das muss das wird auch noch raum geben
dafür darüber zu sprechen sowohl in den
ausbildungseinheiten sie wissen die
junge kollegin war eine fahrschülerin am
ende ihrer ausbildung dort wird darüber
gesprochen werden aber auch in den
anderen einsatzeinheiten dafür ist jetzt
aber im moment nicht die zeit es wird
dafür raum geben jetzt ist die zeit der
ermittlungen die ermittlungen sind noch
nicht zu ende auch wenn zwei
tatverdächtige gefasst sind man musste
auch in der in der bezeichnung sie tun
das immer sehr präzise bleiben es sind
zwei tatverdächtige die polizei
ermittelt aber bald dass sie darf sich
weder auf personen noch auf ein
bestimmtes szenario festlegen sondern
sie muss tatsächlich buchstäblich so
langweilig wie er sich anhört in alle
richtungen ermitteln man kann zu diesem
zeitpunkt wahrscheinlich auch noch nicht
ausschließen dass noch weitere menschen
beteiligt sind oder die polizei darf das
nicht ausschließen sonst würde man ihren
vorwurf machen zu früh die ermittlungen
abgebrochen zu haben dass die
ermittlungen gehen weiter die beiden
tatverdächtigen bislang zumindest so die
information schweigen das ist ihr gutes
recht umso mehr umso wichtiger ist es
dass die polizei mit der
staatsanwaltschaft unter führung der
staatsanwaltschaft jetzt in diesem
strafverfahren alle beweise sicherheit
alle spuren sichert das gesamte
polizeiliche einsatzgeschehen und die
ermittlungstätigkeit akribisch
dokumentiert denn es wird später
möglicherweise in einem
gerichtsverfahren ganz wichtig sein dass
alles da zulegen wenn die beschuldigten
weiter schwer wenn sie haben zu beginn
des gesprächs gesagt dass die polizei
heute viel viel besser ausgerüstet ist
als das noch früher der fall war was
sind trotzdem weitere maßnahmen die noch
verbessert werden können um die polizei
besser zu schützen hört zumindest hat
die polizei
auch wird das habe ich ganz vergessen
das wallis von rheinland-pfalz
ausgegangen ist damals der damalige nrw-
innenminister fritz behrens hat dafür
gesorgt dass in rheinland pfalz das
pilotprojekt mit den kameras in den
streifenwagen angeführt wurde heute ist
das schon standard bei anhalts vorgehen
zumindest bei streifenwagen insbesondere
in den ländlichen regionen ist es
wichtig dass man nicht der irrigen
annahme unterlegt dass man hier die
polizei aus dünnen könnte denn es ist in
solchen einsatzsituation das hat man
hier gesehen das haben wir in vielen
anderen fällen wieder gesehen dass es
wichtig ist so schnell wie möglich
unterstützungskräfte heranzuführen und
deshalb verbietet es sich hier die
kräfte auszudünnen oder die
dienststellen zu schließen das hat es in
der vergangenheit leider mal immer
wieder gegeben glücklicherweise ist der
trend jetzt etwas umgekehrt das heißt
die länder stellen wieder mehr personal
ein das ist auch richtig so auch auf dem
land braucht es eine respektable
polizeidichte die es uns ermöglicht auch
im einzelfall schnell
unterstützungskräfte und
sicherungskräfte heranzuführen ja wenn
die gewalt gegen polizisten gegen
einsatzkräfte ist in den letzten jahren
deutlich gestiegen man hat aber auch das
gefühl dass die qualität noch mal eine
andere geworden ist dass das ganze noch
viel brutaler viel aggressiver geworden
ist was glauben sie woran das liegt das
hat etwas mit der entwicklung in unserer
gesellschaft zu tun zunächst einmal
wissen wir wir nehmen es nicht nur an
sondern wir wissen weil die polizei ein
sehr differenziertes lagebild erstellt
seit einigen jahren wir wissen die
steigerungsraten wir wissen auch in
welchen einsatzsituationen es passiert
manchmal hat man den eindruck dass nur
bei großeinsätzen gewalt gegen der
einsatzkräfte stattfindet dem ist nicht
so mehr als 80 prozent aller attacken
passieren im täglichen streifendienst
bei relativ harmlosen anlässen bei der
verkehrskontrolle wie hier bei und
unfallaufnahme bei der ruhestörung bei
einsätzen die wir früher einfach mal so
bewältigt haben wo man nicht davon
ausgegangen ist dass es eine
gefahrensituation geben könnte aus
solchen alltäglichen situationen
entwickelt sich häufig brutalste gewalt
das hat etwas mit unserer gesellschaft
zu tun mit der verrohung in unserer
gesellschaft mit der abnahme von respekt
gegenüber dem staat insgesamt es gibt
viele menschen die glauben der staat hat
mir alles zu geben aber nichts zu sagen
darüber muss man sprüche hat die politik
an dieser stelle versagt muss da auch
ein bisschen nachgearbeitet werden
eventuell also was die politik angeht
wünsche ich mir manchmal dass respekt
und achtung gegenüber den einsatzkräften
deutlicher wird da ist noch viel luft
nach oben manche pauschale beschimpfung
der polizei als rassistisch rassistische
schlägerbande könnte unterbleiben und
auch mancher untersuchen könnte man sich
in dieser richtung sparen bei der ist
die beleidigung schon im titel der
untersuchung enthalten ich wünsche mir
respekt und achtung und politischen
rückhalt der polizei da ist noch viel
luft nach oben aber von einem pauschalen
politik versagen würde ich nicht
sprechen wollen vielen dank für das
gespräch